الطفله مريم تتردد على هذا المكان عده
مرات في اليوم للحصول على ماء تنقله الى
منزلها البعيد في هذه العبوات الثقيله
التي تؤدي الى الام في جسدها الضعيف ولكن
الحاجه ام التغلب على المشاكل مهما كانت
عبوات ونوبه لتعبئتها بعيده وستصل بعد
فتره طويله ولا يوجد ماء في منزلنا حميد
الله شاب يعيش في هذه المنطقه كان يشتغل
بدابته هذه في افران الطوب خارج العاصمه
كامبول ولكن سنحت له فرصه عمل قريب من
منزله وهي نقل المياه في عبوات على دابته
الى منازل الناس والطلب كثير كما يقول خلق
الناس في ضيق شديد من الماء والماء في
الحنفيات ياتي لفتره قصيره فانا اقوم بنقل
المياه لكل من يحتاج ولا يستطيع نقلها
بنفسه
المهندس عزيز الرحمن عزيزي مسؤول موارد
المياه الجوفيه بوزاره الطاقه والمياه
يعترف بانخفاض منسوب المياه الجوفيه في
العاصمه كابول معزي ذلك الى تغير المناخ
وتراجع الامطار
فادي هذا الوضع الكارثي وضعنا خطه مختلفه
بتفعيلها سنتغلب على هذا الوضع وفي
مقدمتها لائحه تتحكم في الاستخدام المفرط
للمياه الجوفيه
يعرب عدد كبير من سكان كابولا عن قلقهم
حيال الجفاف المتزايد بشكل حاد وانخفاض
منسوب المياه الجوفيه مطالبين السلطات في
كابولا ببذل جهود اضافيه لتوفير المياه
النظيفه لهم يعتقد خبراء البيئه الافغان
ان الاستخدام العشوائيه والمفرط للمياه
الجوفيه في مراكز غسل السجاد والسيارات
والحمامات وغيرها يسبب وفي انخفاض المياه
الذي خلق مشاكله للمواطن الافغاني العادي
الذي يصب عليه شراء مياه الشرب
العربيه كابول لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات